good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend we get
right Friday getting down on Friday
that's right congratulations
it's class of 2004. we did it it is
Friday congrats Jax congrats
thank you Claude you know I need this
Friday I need the weekend it's been a
jam-packed week for your girl so much
toast so much driving I went out two
nights this week like crazy I am Thai
red the girl is beat the girl is beat so
I'm looking forward to the weekend
looking forward to this Friday show a
little it's gonna be a very Friday
episode I feel because the stories are
light as air yeah it's a it's a mixed
bag and the girlies are tired so you
never know what you're gonna get when
you have that combination I just feel
like whenever we have a show like this
right after we rap something major
happens I mean it was like last week
that Raquel and Tom's Scandal came out
after like a measly Friday episode yeah
and I just can't wait to see what the
universe has in store for us at 11 30.
you want to make a prediction let's take
the craziest thing that could happen
it's a good question
what's so crazy it's like you would
never predict that's the point right
that's the thing you can't predict it
because it's so crazy and unpredictable
it's unpredictable oh
what song is that unbelievable oh that's
what I thought but I'm like that's not
the words yeah I just I kind of improved
um got a musical like that you're kind
of like a Jonas brother likes just
singing and dancing I'm a Jonas sister
for sure but I'm Kevin because you don't
want to hear me on the mic but I have a
lot to contribute to the group I'm so
glad you brought that up because so last
night me and snitch went to the Jonas
brothers are doing this really cool
thing it's like promo for their new
album
um where they took over a Broadway
Theater in New York City this entire
week and every night they're doing a
show and every night they're focusing on
one of their albums so last night was
lines Vines and trying times and like I
chose to go to that one because to me
lines finds and trying times is such an
iconic album do you not agree it's such
an iconic album if I could go to any one
of their albums
can I may I I would have gone to the
night before which was like Jonas
Brothers
no that was their first one and then
there was the second one that had like
when you look me in the eyes
[Music]
okay I just need to look oh a little bit
longer yes a little bit longer and I'll
beat that and that's also burning up
so good you know it took me no way
Jackie you know what burning up means to
me right high heels for a dress oh no
um color war and school not great color
War like we had to write a cheer and our
team like all the the school was split
up into teams and every team was a
different element so the ninth graders
were fire
um
and we went to a Jewish Day School so it
was like partially Hebrew too so fire in
in Hebrew is aish and we were like a
pretty fire song to burning up
um I forget how it goes
I would imagine we're hot I've yeah of
course they're cold I've sung it on the
toast before
um
how does the chorus go
it was in Hebrew I don't remember
whatever we're trying to keep from going
under so Margo and I went to the concert
last night
I would have assumed that like lines
Vines and trying times is like
like one of their better albums and I
guess I'm not really like deep into the
fandom so like everyone who was there
was like giggling before the show
started and I was like what am I missing
and the Jonas Brothers get on stage and
they basically say like we we know this
is like our flop album I'm like what
I had no idea and then they were
explaining you know they had just had a
little bit longer which had sold like
500 000 copies and yes Lions Vines and
trying times when
number one but it sold 200 000 copies
and you know the label never put out a
second single and that was the last
album they did together for the like for
the next 10 years wow and they were like
you know we really experimented a lot on
this album with like country with
Orchestra with R and B and then I did
remember there's this like moronic song
on the album with common
let me go look it's called something
don't do a crime something of a crime
and everyone like before the show was
talking like do you think they're gonna
sing in the comments don't charge me for
the crime
and
the Jonas Brothers they go in order and
when it came up to that common song they
started to play it and then they're like
no we're kidding we're not playing that
song it's it's really it's horrible oh
my God I have to listen to it now and
then when I was like sitting through
with the album like I'm like yeah I
guess it is this kind of like mixed bag
of different genres like it is a little
all over the place but it's not bad by
any means like there really are a few
you know they're iconic bangers and math
my favorite Jonas Brothers song is on
this album which I guess makes it like
if you go by that standard like maybe
it's my favorite album because I need
this one song and that's why what is it
fly with it yeah oh my god with me is
the Bop of the century so like how could
it be a flop album with their best song
on it and they did before the storm on
that album too before the storm and also
much better is teleconic because it's
like a slam song whatever those are
called world war three no you can't have
a Whirlpool three so good I like
honestly I don't agree that it's like
their flop album but like they believe
it the fans believe it but they were
like all along for the ride and I guess
I really didn't like put into
perspective that it was the last thing
they did for 10 years
um and it was the thing that like really
tore them apart and it is kind of all
over the place like they had a fiddler
come from one of the songs where they
were clearly experimenting with country
they had like an orchestra of strings
come in for when they were clearly
experimenting with strings so it is all
over the place but I enjoyed it I think
the best album that I would probably the
concert I would want to go to is the
Jonas Brothers album because there's SOS
hold on good night and goodbye that's
just the way we roll hello beautiful
when you look me in the eyes
just friends
I think I would still want to go to a
little bit longer
a little bit longer has oh just burning
up love bug
a little bit longer a little bit longer
and down wait so the reason why I
brought it up is because you know I'm
constantly one thing about me I'm
constantly studying the Dynamics of the
Jonas Brothers like I find it
interesting especially given the fact
that they actually broke up for 10 years
because of set Dynamics
um and you know in the beginning and
they had referenced this and they do
every time they talk about the split how
like Kevin was really towards the end
like feeling uninspired and Nick and Joe
like were like starting to leave him out
and doing performances without him and
he just said like he was feeling left
out and he wasn't you know feeling it
and he was not practicing the guitar and
not practicing yeah he's like he said I
was playing the notes but I wasn't
reading between the lines damn poetic
and I just want to say last night Kevin
was reading between the lines like he
was giving everything he was giving
vocals he was giving dancing like to me
it's always like oh who's the star
knicker Joe Kevin was a star Kevin's a
glue because Kevin's blue and their egos
are so so inflated they're gonna fly
away but Kevin is the one that tethers
them to the ground and so Margo and I
were seated right behind Kevin's
daughters oh my God Jackie you never saw
something so cute they were gripped like
literally white knuckling the bar in
front of them is staring at their dad
like dying for his attention waving and
he knew where they were and it was a
really small theater so he waved to them
like a thousand times and it wasn't
enough like every time I got a wave they
needed another wave it was so cute and
they all had little iPhones they were
like zooming in on their dad and they
brought friends like it just made me
think like how cool to have and you know
rock stars are rock stars but I feel
like Kevin Jonas is really normal he's
like a family guy I saw a comment that
said like Kevin Jonas was put on this
Earth to be a dad and a part-time rock
star and it's so true and I just thought
like how cool to be like a girl and you
know all young girls like idolize their
dads but like your dad actually is an
idol it was so me and Margo we were
watching the kids more than we were
watching the show it was so cute that is
so cute it was adorable it was a great
it's actually a really good concept for
like promo for your album we were gonna
go tonight which is happiness begins but
we've seen happiness begins at MSG so I
thought when am I ever going to be able
to hear lines buttons and trying times
no it was a moment in time that's for
sure it was a moment in time and I guess
maybe I look like I see the album you
know in perspective as being so iconic
simply because of the title
oh yeah the title is ever Lions lines
and trying times like it was everything
yeah but it wasn't
no I can understand how they got carried
away with themselves like they were at
their Peak I'm sure the record label was
like oh my God we just broke records to
do another one do a flip and they're
like okay let's do let's try this yeah
and it flopped but not to me
no no me neither I didn't even know I
didn't know like the undercurrent of
drama until I got there and everyone's
like lines Vines and trying times I'm
like yeah line signs and trying times
that's such a good title um so it was a
great night out with a snitch which is
always tell me about her it was great
you know she worked so hard I feel like
when I see her on weekdays she's like
like kind of a toxic chaotic energy yeah
like toxic workplace
unwinding and yesterday you know she
worked so hard and she also has been
kind of taken my my co-pilot see it in
this Nashville Taylor Swift she's got
the spreadsheet going she started the
group chat she has another job now she's
finding accommodations like she actually
once I got the suite which I take full
credit for counselor really took the
reins and I think she was like mad at me
yesterday because she heard on the toast
like I didn't credit her with like doing
much but I said I'm like you didn't do
anything at the time that I recorded I
said when I record tomorrow I will give
you proper credit which is who the [__]
said that I know I was a little my
antennas went up I'm like you're
listening to the toes no she didn't so
someone literally went out of their way
to tell her Claudia took credit for the
Box people are always taking [__] we say
about Margo out of context and like
gaslighting her in her DMS and then she
doesn't even listen she just takes what
that person says and gases us up for it
I know but it's great because then like
she yells at us and it's like you need
to listen to the episode if you if you
didn't listen to the episode then you
can't yell at us no end either it means
like she'll listen to our episode which
is so cool for us or she has to drop it
well she's yelling at us um which means
she's talking to us which is great it's
a form of communication yeah 100 100
um
so it was a great night out with the
snitch a gno great night out
great night out yeah so that's what I
did what did you do I said you were like
out and about I was out and about I was
at my friend Erica's birthday party he
was a little karaoke sushi party and it
was so fun I hadn't like gone out like
I've gone out to dinner a little bit but
I haven't gone out to like a party in
forever so I was partying two things
about your party one
our sister Olivia is such a queen
because like I just know her so well and
one thing I know about Olivia is she
actually does not like to wear colored
lipstick like she's very again even
though she has the biggest she doesn't
wear lipstick period she will wear a
clear gloss maybe like a little tint to
Pink but she does not like not even a
little like I try and get her to put on
my lipsticks all the time and it's so
unfair because if you ever studied
Olivia's face you will see the perfect
pair of lips like it's actually she's
undeserving so you guys were taking a
bunch of pictures at this birthday party
you were out last night and Olivia had
like this kind of merlot looking tint to
her lips and I'm like I know that [__]
is drinking red wine because she never
wears lipstick yeah and you know what
she looked gorgeous gotta get her a
Merlot lip stain she should start a line
of like wine stained lip stains yeah
because she clearly likes that I thought
the same thing when I was looking
through my pictures I was like he's got
a nice lipstick on it was nice the
second thing speaking of you went to a
sushi party I didn't even tell you this
but you know I'm doing my series on
social media where I try new foods I've
never tried before because you guys know
I'm the pickiest eater and I forgot that
I recorded this because I had like been
like drunk at dinner and I just recorded
it and I literally forgot about it until
two days ago I was scrolling through my
camera roll I tried um spicy tuna sushi
so I heard the uh I was driving Olivia
and she like I guess her phone was
malfunctioning and it kept restarting
your video I I'm like however you open
your video it was the first five seconds
over and over and over again I like got
the point that you were trying to sushi
but I was driving so I couldn't watch at
all and I have no idea what happens in
the video now okay so let me tell you
how I tried spicy General let me say I
went to a place called sake nohana and
the spicy tuna roll that was like on the
sushi platter did not have seaweed in it
it was just rice usually doesn't oh it
doesn't no it's usually crispy rice
spicy tuna avocado maybe a little sauce
and a jalapeno that you could take it or
leave it no I'm sorry I'm not talking
about crispy rice I'm talking about
spicy tuna roll oh okay yes a roll would
have CBDs yeah and I've had spicy tuna
crispy rice and I like that because it's
literally like fried food but I've never
had like a proper sushi roll okay so it
was rice it was rice around
tuna
with like a layer like a little fillet
of avocado on top I don't know how they
held it together without the seaweed was
there like rice paper or something no
okay and so that's why I was like a
little bit more open to trying it
because I do not [__] with seaweed like
I don't like the smell it makes me like
it's so fishy
um and I tried it and let me tell you
how good it was
so good it was I was shocked I ate the
whole thing it was delicious
but now how do I go to a sushi
restaurant and order a spicy tuna roll
with no seaweed just try that see what
happens okay it might be like falling
apart a little bit but you don't care
about what it looks like just what it
tastes like no maybe you had like a rice
paper I don't know it had something yeah
try it with rice paper instead of
seaweed it was so good and like then I
dipped it in soy sauce and I was living
or you could even get it cucumber lime
no I need rice cucumber and rice when
she Lou
I don't need to add like a vegetable
into the mix you know you love a
cucumber you are a cucumber okay I don't
love cucumber like I definitely will eat
cucumber like I tolerate cucumbers
you're obsessed Beyond I'm obsessed
no like if somebody's like to eat
vegetables I'm like yeah I'll eat a
cucumber yeah and you like how I make
you a bowl of cucumbers with a little
salt I do ever like a really dry
cucumber like I think people like need
to start like drying their cucumbers and
then like a little pinch of salt I think
that's delicious
I saw recently that you're not supposed
to keep cucumbers in the fridge really
we need a master list of where fruits
and veggies are supposed to go because I
keep stuff in the fridge that apparently
I'm not supposed to and I keep stuff in
my fruit bowl that apparently is
supposed to go in the fridge like lemons
yeah that makes sense avocado I saw this
guy putting in the fridge do you put
onions in your fridge no you're not
supposed to yeah okay I just learned
that Ben is like always leaving them out
I might put them in the fridge he's like
no they don't go in they don't go in the
fridge but they're ugly and they're
smelly so I wish I could tuck them away
and then so then I'm I've been starting
like a drawer of
ugly
counter items such as onions potatoes
garlic
and now I have a smelly drawer no and
it's like okay sometimes you only need
half an onion so what do you do with the
other half you leave it on the counter
no you put it in tin foil and you put it
in the fridge until it rots and then you
could throw it away oh okay good that's
what I've been doing yeah yeah that's
the right thing to do
aye aye Captain good to know I'm doing
something right because you're never
gonna actually use it you're just unless
it's almost magically the next day you
need an onion but you don't no you never
do never do and if you bought a bag of
onions like I did I'm never gonna get
through the bag so I might as well use a
fresh onion instead of this old one from
the fridge I'm never gonna reach for
like the thing that's half open oh and
I'm never gonna remember that that's
what that ball of tin foil in my fridge
is a hundred percent and I'm never gonna
even open it to find out what it is
because it's scary to open an
unidentified tin foil bowl and you're
pregnant you can't just be like opening
things like the smell you have to take
care of your body you have to protect
yourself 100
um
so yeah I tried Sushi and I couldn't
believe that I actually like I didn't
even just tolerate it like I actually
liked it that's so amazing I'm so glad
it's crazy to the repertoire I know I
think like maybe next time like I will
order like a spicy jooneral yeah when
you like order sushi get spicy tuna no
seaweed and then also order what you
would usually order just in case as a
backup yeah yeah you need backup of
course of course of course
um
so it's just like brief update from
Jackson Claude as we head into the
weekend maybe I'll have sushi this
weekend maybe Jax will go to another
party who knows who knows I don't know
what I'm up to this weekend
Drive ain't gonna take it easy for sure
but it's also fun to like do weekend
things and now that I'm a driver like I
need to keep up this momentum of driving
every day because it's making a huge
difference like by the time you get down
here turdy Lou you me and Tesla are
gonna take the town you're gonna be able
to pick me up from the airport
that's a little extreme unless I can get
there without going on the highway you
definitely cannot no I definitely can it
will take me two hours oh yeah I mean
yeah you could yeah yeah
um wait also oh one thing that's like
annoying about this weekend is Ben's out
of town he's on a golf trip and like I
like have to sleep alone I was up all
night like literally every time I heard
something like it woke me up and I was
just having the worst night's sleep ever
like I hate sleeping alone okay but
would you rather sleep alone because
Ben's not there have been there and find
a can of multi beans have been there and
find a can of moldy beans wow yeah like
nights up like being awake at night and
scared and alone which happens to me
every time Ben's out of town is one of
my least favorite life experiences as a
human being yeah no I understand that
completely and I don't know how they
would ever do it in a house oh my God
yeah why don't you invite like someone
to sleep over what about the snitch what
if you said snitch like why don't you
see occasion at my place this weekend
the dogs could be together she would
literally never Margo loves her
apartment like I respect that I do but
she would never but if you pack up your
things and go to the snitches she's a
queen size bed honestly like I don't
think it's enough for the two of us and
the dogs
and the dogs why don't you just ask her
and invite her like see what she says
let me send her a text like I'll leave
her response on it she's gonna think
you're like choking but try and say it
in a way that she knows you're serious
Ben's out of town this weekend comma do
you want to pack up your stuff and bring
Magnolia and spend the weekend question
mark write slumber party exclamation
point like a slumber party
she's gonna roast me this is a cute idea
just be like no I'm gonna have this and
this and I just can't I have no time no
100 she's like you're so are you serious
you know I have this and this is weekend
let's see what she says
delivered
this is like a form of self-harm a
hundred percent like putting yourself in
the most vulnerable position and like
knowing the results but doing it you're
about to see it like pummeled Beyond I'm
like actually afraid
wouldn't that be fun for you yeah of
course check in on me in like 10 minutes
because I always forget the last time I
I was like let me text Olivia you guys
remember that like two weeks ago and
then and I just want to say so the thing
was I was telling you that Olivia uses
all lowercase in her phone it's like set
to Auto lower case at least it used to
be all of her contacts are lowercase
whatever so Claudia like didn't believe
me so I was like at text her and ask for
an old friend's number and I'm telling
you it will come through the contact
will come through with lowercase so you
and it did and it did lower and lower M
lower K our sisters should know if we're
ever texting them between the hours of
10 30 and 12 like they're being set up
it's happening on the podcast it's a
trap if it feels like a trap you're
already like the thing is it's not like
this isn't a trap for Margo we hope she
says yes
no it's definitely a trap like we're
it's literally entrapment like we know
the results and we're doing it anyway
but we're really hoping that she yeah
we're hoping she doesn't fall for it but
we know she will you try it also
speaking of Taylor Swift lyrics to
tonight is opening night of the eras in
Glendale I'm like I have like I actually
have regrets for not going because it's
the one show that Paramore is opening
for and I know Ben would have [__]
loved that who's opening in Nashville
Grace it depends it's different every
literally every single night in
Nashville
um the one that we're going to I believe
is Gracie Abrams but the night before is
free freebie Bridgers and that's why
Margaret wanted to do Friday night but
everybody else said Saturday night she
likes Phoebe Bridgers
I don't know I don't
Margaret's like just like on the pulse
of like what's cool you know like always
I know Phoebe Bridgers is cool but I
also know snitch's music taste no snitch
loves that song funeral
oh my God we wouldn't even make it in
time for the opener knowing us no of
course not we gotta go to dinner we have
20 people well that's a lot of Ubers to
call
um so not only is it opening night
tonight wishing everyone the best
um but Taylor also surprised us
yesterday by releasing four songs
three of them are not new unless you're
like a new Taylor Swift fan you probably
haven't heard them but there is one new
song are they on other albums or they're
like from the target Edition no they're
oh that's a really good question no
they're not on the target Edition
they're from other albums actually like
where are they from well okay so safe
and sound was a song She Wrote for The
Hunger Games I know it I believe eyes
open is also for the Hunger Games love
and then if this was a movie She
released as a vault track for Fearless
but I thought it was on speak now
and does it go if we were movie no it
goes come back come back do you know
that one keep going it sounds familiar
come back come back come back to me
what do you think the next word is
come back come back come back to me now
oh okay so she literally I my whole life
I thought it was come back come back
come back to me Eli you would you would
if this was a movie and I guess that was
like Taylor's era of like kind of
slurring her words and singing in
cursive but I'm not the only person who
thought it was Eli but when she
re-recorded it she's a little bit more
um
pronunciative
and I am now realizing it's come back
come back come back to me like you would
you would if this was a move um the
whole time I thought you were singing to
some guy Eli I'm like oh lucky for him
yeah he's like Stephen hey right that
was her era reasons Drew yeah of calling
people out right and like nobodies
nobodies but then they became somebody's
and she was like nah oh speaking of
Taylor calling people out you know one
of the songs online signs and trying
times much better is a song Joe wrote
about Taylor after she had written
better than revenge
um and it's like actually a really mean
song and it's very clearly about Taylor
he references like the Teardrops On My
Guitar he references a superstar and he
did give a little speech before because
it's like you know like a song like that
might not fly same as it says in age
well and neither better than revenge is
not does not age well very mean it's
very mean and it's like it's pitting
women you know it's taking blaming women
for men's Discretions yeah yeah so his
song doesn't age well in neither does
hers
um but he made like a little speech and
like everybody knew what song was coming
up next because they were going in
chronological order and he was just like
you know we've all moved past it uh
we're all grown up he was like giggling
and everyone was giggling and it was
clear like there's no bad blood you know
I love everyone and so if I felt okay
singing along because it is kind of like
a Bop yeah for sure I'm sure everyone's
really happy about it except for Camilla
Bell who really just never bounced back
from all of this you are so [__]
right I'm sure everyone's having a nice
big laugh about it and we can now
perform it and like you know take the
sting out of it but it still stings for
her was Camilla Bell in Monte Carlo
no oh just everyone in it looks like her
okay Margo answered and you know what
she obviously said no but it was kind of
sweet oh
I love you dearly and that is so cute of
you but I enjoy my bed and my home too
much I literally knew she was gonna say
that do I know the snitch you do
it still hurts
let me come here for the weekend
I have two events on Saturday night
events events you want to go to events
events events I want to go to events
invite me to go over events what are the
events uh Remy's birthday party and then
another friend's birthday party oh
cool just like birthday Central cool
yeah sorry
it might have been a good time for me to
come if I wasn't literally coming like
in a week and a half yeah no I mean I
feel like I gave you like a lot of
really good options um out of options
unless like one of your friends
listening to this episode like happens
to also be solo this weekend wants to
sleep at 30s it's a summer party at
charities everyone's welcome or if
someone wants to like invite you to stay
with them and they have like you know a
situation that would be turdy friendly
yeah like a gorgeous guest room on the
beach right right right right no but you
have events events events I want to go
to events invite me to your events
so I feel like it's time yeah we like
low-key dilly-dally for 30 minutes even
though we had like nothing of value to
say it's good because we have even less
of value to say in the stories which are
the fast five stories that I'm not going
to say that you need to know like I
won't but you do need to listen to every
episode of this show and that will
include this hodgepodge of stories
Jackie here are the fast five stories
that you
that you are about to hear no by the way
here are the fast five stories
here are the Fantastic stories gulp
and today's fast five stories that you
certainly do not need to know are
brought to you by Hulu's new show up
here up here is a musical series rom-com
about two characters Lindsay and Miguel
juggling career and crushes as they try
to find love in New York City in 1999
featuring original music up here as a
rom-com all about falling in love and
discovering that the greatest obstacle
to finding happiness together is
yourself well yourself in the
treacherous world of obsession fears
memories and Fantasies that live inside
our heads it premieres on Hulu March
24th and it's from the director of
Hamilton the screenwriter of tick Tick
boom and the songwriters uh from The
Book of Mormon and one division it's a
true collaboration of experts in their
disciplines Thomas Kill from Hamilton
Stephen Levinson from Tick Tick boom
Kristen and Bobby Lopez from The Book of
Mormon and Juan division it's a story
about two characters Lindsay Miguel
trying to find love in the big city this
is a story about the opinions of friends
and family and how they manifest as
voices in your head oh my that's so true
up here takes the inner voices of Family
and friends and shoves them into the
daily lives of these everyday New
Yorkers it's filled with raunch and
Ridiculousness up here is about that
magical time in your life when you had
nothing figured out and all the time in
which to think about it I love that I
love that there are so many fabulous
creators on this project and I love a
musical especially a spring musical
which is exactly what up here on Hulu is
you can stream the musical rom-com up
here on Hulu beginning March 24th so
mark your calendars again the rom-com
musical it's called up here it's on Hulu
March 24th today's episode is also
brought to you by betterhelp
think you better help for sponsoring
today's episode Getting to Know Yourself
can be a lifelong process especially
because we're always growing and
changing I mean we were saying that
yesterday look at me here Wellness
Advocate
tongue scraping Advocate tongue scraping
wedge you never would have seen that for
me last year so therapy is all about
deepening your self-awareness and your
understanding because sometimes we don't
know what we want or why we react to the
way that we do until we talk through
things better help connects you with a
licensed therapist who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are so whether or not
you've
tried therapy I think better help is a
great
um resource because it's so accessible
it's so easy you don't have to get up
and do all the awkward things that are
like required with traditional therapy
like waiting in a in a waiting room with
other people making eye contact can be
so hard and then if you don't end up
liking your therapist it can be kind of
discouraging to go and find another one
but better help makes it really easy to
switch therapists if you're not jiving
with the first or second one which is
totally normal so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely done online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire and you'll get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge discover your
potential with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com toast today get to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
help.com toast thank you you're welcome
our first story The View hosts are being
slammed for not asking Hugh Grant about
his rude Ashley Graham interview so Hugh
Grant went on The View this week to
promote his new film Dungeons and
Dragons honor among thieves and all the
co-hosts noticeably avoided the elephant
in the room instead the ladies disgust
the Stars reunion with his former
co-star Annie McDowell on the Oscars
stage where they presented together for
the best production design so he went
there did a Fluff interview he's
obviously headline news this week
because of his viral moment with Ashley
Graham and you know these journalists
didn't ask about it and the the tweeters
were very disappointed I get a Fluff
interview I respect it
but the view is not you know
historically a place where you
can even do a Fluff interview that's
what they're known for you know
hard-hitting angle you know opinions
from all sides of the political Spectrum
yada yada like they're known to be like
or at least maybe not recently but you
know it's like the Lion's Den if you're
going yeah you're going into the lion's
den and we're gonna mention it all right
so I think this is a like very losery of
the view and I'm sure that they were
told by Hugh Grant's people like we're
not talking about this Ashley Graham
thing but the view in this particular
scenario has the power the view is the
bigger show they don't they don't need
the The View doesn't need Hugh Grant
yeah like they could get anyone on the
show I think this is so losery and like
so lame and I think it really um
lowers a lot of the respect I think
people have for the view and just like
their journalistic could it get lower
turdy Lou do you think no I know I mean
I don't think the view is at one point
are you still like really respect the
view
um and I thought it was like a great
idea but I just think like over the last
few years it's kind of become a mess and
I feel like EV literally every time I
see something about the view it's
somebody apologizing for saying
something like incredibly offensive yeah
um
so I I don't respect it in the way that
I used to and so hearing something like
this is like actually not shocking but I
think like the not the current state of
the view but like the view franchise the
view of is better than this the view is
better where it would never never
Barbara Walters would never no Sherry
Shepard would never Elizabeth Hasselbeck
never and like when you break it down
it's not like
what happened between them is so
unspeakable you know like right even if
the publicist said we don't want to talk
about it like you still could talk about
it and Hugh Grant could just say what
was going through his mind like honestly
it's really not that taboo no it's not
something you have to like actively
avoid it's not the biggest Scandal of
the century but it's so on the cusp of
what everyone is talking about right now
if this interview was this is like
literally the week after the Oscars if
it was next week okay maybe a little bit
more I could understand but it's so of
the moment right now the view would have
been better off just not having him as a
guest yeah because now they just look
weak they look weak and losery and
they're just like a bunch of Hollywood
celebs protecting other Hollywood celebs
and you know there are enough like so
podcasts and interviewees who do that
that we don't need that like that's what
we're tuning into the view for it used
to be this like Spitfire you couldn't
believe some of the [__] you were
hearing like that's what it used to be
yeah no but I do want to hear about
Dungeons and Dragons right honor among
Thieves no like that's the game you play
when you have something to promote like
you go and talk about the thing you are
wanting to talk about but then you also
have to talk about [__] you don't want
to talk about you have to give an
interesting engaging interview it's not
really just like fluff unless you're
going you know on
um
I don't even know I don't want to offend
anyone but no I know but like unless
you're going on The View because that's
the reputation they're going to have now
yeah yeah unless you're going on The
View it's like oh I want to go to a
Fluff interview let me book The View
[Music]
and no one used to ever say that no oh
man I wrote about this in my book you
know when we were canceled I this was
we got an email from The View they were
like do you guys want to come on and
like you know talk about it
did I want did I want to talk about a
period no did I want to talk about it on
the [__] view like Lion's Den
absolutely not now if I got that email
and [__] was happening in 2020 maybe I
would I think I could go for a fourth
interview on The View they might want to
talk about your my commitment to you
know
um Holocaust Education yeah no they
probably wouldn't Whoopi wouldn't want
to talk about that no what he's been
saying like a lot of crazy shows yeah
and she keeps saying the same thing
pretty much and then like apologizing
but then like saying that you know the
same thesis again oh also like total
tangent but speaking of Whoopi Goldberg
um when we were having conversation last
week about sequels that are just as good
if not better than the original Sister
Act
because the sequel is with Lauryn Hill
yeah
it's actually this that's when she like
becomes a teacher and all the kids like
travel in the sequel and it's actually
it's better than the first
damn I think I actually saw Sister Act
two before I even saw Sister Act One and
then I went back and watched it
interesting
he taught me how oh he taught me how
like Sister Act 2 had my Jewish ass at
like the age of 11 singing you know
about Jesus washing my sins away and he
did he watched my sins away oh happy day
oh happy day oh happy day repeat after
me Jack's ready
he
hit her oh it's a big house such like
literally that scene chills that's a
good song for remote podcasting a little
call and repeat yes yes because we can't
really [__] up and sing like
off noted and that one from Passover
yes
you know if you know you know that's it
if you know you know like that Passover
kind of like prayer I don't want to like
say it and like
I don't know why I feel like it's like
desecrating the part that I just did
like doesn't have like the lord's name
so we're fine
um no you know you know it's a literally
pop season I don't know who put that
Melody to that song but like Grammy
and you should see the Australia family
seder is when that part comes up and we
all know at this point like turdy's
taking the lead on that yeah and we're
just her loyal followers but you guys
really bring it like in terms of
background energy
thanks you're welcome
okay ready for our next story just
clearing up some rumors for the from
this week because Zendaya's stylist law
roach is breaking his silence just to
defend his relationship with Zendaya so
as we announced he said he was retiring
this week we speculated to the ends of
the Earth as to what could have happened
even including like you know some sort
of bragus with Zendaya but he is
clearing that up saying quote so y'all
really think I'm breaking up with Z We
Are Forever she's my little sister and
it's real love not the fake industry
love
so I just think it was a confusing week
because this this news was you know
Sunday night we were all gagged grouped
and gagged and then throughout the week
like he's walking in the Hugo Boss
fashion show and doing things that you
know a retired Fashion Stylist doesn't
do so he did then clarify that he is
retiring from the celebrity styling
element of his work but his work
includes other things besides that so
now he could still model he could still
be a judge on fashion shows he could
still design or whatever other things
that he is doing even though his main
beat is the celebrity styling
do you think he'll still style Zendaya
though I don't know it's all just so
unclear so unclear
but just wanted to clear that up because
that would be really sad I also feel
like Zendaya thus far in her career has
really managed to avoid any sort of like
drama like I can't think of anything
even though I think a lot of people
speculate is there weirdness between her
and Bella Thorne there's actually not
like she's really avoided any sort of
Confrontation or like internet drama or
Scandal and I'm curious what her
thoughts are on this yeah because I feel
like she's she doesn't do that
no but she must know what happened yeah
to make him feel this way so I'm sure
she just supports him hopefully we have
to do like everyone needs to just do
what is best for them you know you can't
prioritize space where you don't feel
valued and you just feel like
especially when you're at the top of
your game no no is that how you feel
about the toast or at the top of your
game and you don't feel valued no did I
say that no it just sounded like you
were speaking on experience honestly
like no no I'm just like speaking as to
how that might feel okay I was just I'm
just checking in always you know no no I
feel I feel valued okay good I'm there
you feel supported like as a mother and
a woman yeah yeah I do okay yeah okay
good just so important to constantly be
checking in but it is like so crazy and
we were talking about this like there's
no reference point really that we have
for like
someone who does a Daily Show
a female who does a Daily Show whether
it be like podcast or TV and they're
real like there's no like backup posts
and we're and I'm trying to have babies
yeah no it's hard and over the next like
five ten years when we're both having
babies it's gonna be a hodgepodge of
maternity leave drama right but like
we'll still be here we'll be doing as
many shows as we can but we don't even
have something to reference as like
because that's what they do yeah what
did they do like I was saying like what
if Joe Rogan was a woman and he was
having kids right and even Joe Rogan
doesn't do every single day he does like
I think three right and he also can Bank
episodes because they're just
conversations right and so that's what
does a topical show there are a lot of
people like on
um networks and stuff who do that but
you have a whole network behind you yeah
there's placements GMA has a million
hosts if someone's out for maternity
like you don't even notice because
there's so many people like yeah someone
is at the helm of a Daily Show Who's
like needs to take maternity leave
sometimes I don't know and I think like
even the closest reference are like
weekly podcasters who again are not
topical and can Bank bank episode so I
don't know
right but even like a female weekly
podcaster who's in who's tops of the
charts
and has done maternity leave in their
podcast
I feel like Lauren Bostic yeah but they
bank they bank that's what I'm saying
like when you do interviews or things
that aren't like news topical it's easy
to bank yeah yeah that's a lot but it's
a bit it's a lot of banking but then you
can Bank just as much as time you want
off you could literally think for a year
right yeah
so so but I still feel supported we're
figuring it out together but there's
nothing to
reference reference we love principles
that are set me too I love a president
there's no precedent here zero drop a
comment if you know of a precedent yeah
yeah
yeah are you ready for our next story a
little more clarification today I it's
just a clarifying Friday I love when
things become clear you know because Ben
Affleck is on the cover of Hollywood
reporter's new feature issue he's
talking about a lot of things
um the thing we'll be focusing on is
he's revealing the moment he appeared
miserable at the Grammys he's revealing
what happened between him and his wife
so he denies having a bad time at the
2023 Grammys and claims his viral
unenthused space was due to the host
Trevor nowhere catching him off guard
for a skip he said I saw Trevor approach
and I was like oh God they were framing
Us in the shop but I didn't know they
were rolling just before the skip began
cameras captured uh Ben having a
conversation with his wife JLo he said
she had been uh he's the star
I'm sorry Ben said he had been joking
with his wife telling her as soon as
they start rolling I'm going to slide
away from you and leave you sitting next
to Trevor
so then she goes you better not [__]
leave that's a husband and wife thing I
mean some of it is I'm like all right
who is this act so in the clip you see
him whisper something and then you see
him move to the side he doesn't know
that they're filming he doesn't know
that he's in frame and then you see her
saying you better not [__] leave
which is exactly what a wife would say
of course and not in any sort of like
acrimonious you know what JLo sounds
like an Aggie [__] wife love it
she sounds like an Aggie [__] wife and
we respect and we love and you know I
didn't really need an expert like this
is so weird to me like
it just happened to be caught on camera
so it became a moment but like people's
like personal
I I don't know like I I don't need an
explanation on this the fact that he has
to come on here and explain what five
seconds taken out of context of him and
his wife when they were really they
thought they weren't being recorded they
weren't purposely putting this content
out like this feels so invasive to me
like they don't owe us no they don't owe
us an explanation I think even when it
happened like I our takeaway was not
that you know this is a miserable couple
who can't stand to be each other like
it's just like this is five seconds in a
lifetime of moments and like sometimes
you just look a little miserable sitting
next to each other no but I think people
need to look inward on their own lives
and think about how many times a day
they look of course to their partner
because that's life but I'm just glad
that he cleared this up one because it's
a very simple explanation and because
clearly this is the truth he's not Ben
Affleck isn't going to make something up
and certainly not going to answer a
question he doesn't want to answer right
but I feel like this is a great moment
that we'll always be able to point to as
like you don't you might see something
and it looks like something but it's not
that something and don't just jump to
the worst conclusions like this to me
makes complete sense and I will use it
as a reference going forward to be like
hey you don't know what was said
just give it a second and by the way
like also just keep in mind like the
context it's such a long day they've
been getting ready for hours they're
standing their backs hurts probably
wearing Spanx he's uncomfortable in his
thing like just you get it's a part of
the human experience it's just getting
irritated and more often than not you
take it out of your partner so like I
don't know I'm not this doesn't make me
think they're headed for Splitsville no
and I I don't even think he was
irritated he just like didn't want to be
a part of the bit and didn't realize him
saying I don't want to be a part of the
bit was part of the bit yeah he didn't
know that it had started plus it was a
really wide lens wider than most 100 you
know they had that fish eye lens on
because at other award shows you don't
get so many background characters no and
when you know you're on camera you're so
like charismatic and it takes so much
energy so that once you stop rolling you
automatically go to misery just so that
you can conserve your energy for when
you have to be like again right also he
said like to him this is his wife's work
event right he thought would be like fun
to go to he said I've been to some movie
award shows like speeches and sound
mixing webinars but I thought this would
be fun and now you have to put yourself
in a situation going to your spouse's
work event and like is it happy go lucky
every minute of the event no facts Jacks
are the facts part two and if they're
about to do like a worky thing you know
you don't want to be a part of it that
would be me a hundred percent and it
would also be me to say you're not
[__] going anywhere oh my God that
would be putting it kindly I'd be like
sit your nasty ass down you [__]
[__] no I'm kidding I would never say
that so honestly this whole Saga
actually I think I have a lot of faith
in this couple they're just a real
couple they're just like us truly I
agree and you know I've been like seeing
a lot of like Paparazzi footage of JLo
spending a lot of time with Ben and Jen
Gardner's kids and she's like a really
involved stepmom and you know vice versa
I think it's really nice like I think
that these women have done a really good
job of like being really mature and like
putting the kids forward they're both
like really good stepmoms and stuff and
I think it's nice so wouldn't you say
they're Blended
I would say they're Blended yes I think
they're blending nicely from what I've
seen that's all you could hope for yeah
and it's tough you know Jen Garner is a
bigger woman than I'd ever be I know but
she's remarried right and she's a
toaster so she's so happy and she's
joying her life since she's a toaster
like yeah we found out this week that
Jen Gardner is a toaster now I'm not
delusional enough to think she's like
sitting down putting on the toast every
day I believe a lot of probably like the
young cool Fabulous Girls who work for
her are toasters and like are you know
keeping her in the loop like oh Jackie
loves Once Upon a farm and that's Jen
Gardner's company but Jen Gardner did
share you know a clip of us on her of
you actually on her stories and used a
bunch of toasty lingos and literally but
she said I'm a toaster
now she didn't say she's a toaster
she wrote like you know we gotta get a
cooler of Once Upon a farm on at the
toast Studio she did say that
but she didn't say the words I am a
toaster I really thought she did because
otherwise I could find it because
yeah me too me too oh okay
I don't think she I mean I'll die but
that would be so like me to like not
read the whole thing
oh imagine you hear that outside it's a
St Patrick's Day Parade I could not get
to work today okay it's not on the story
but it might be in the comment on the
video because like I wouldn't make that
up I'm not like delusional no you
wouldn't make that up but it might be
like a Mandela yes she commented at
Jackie Crasher yes three hearts I'm a
toaster
no [__] way I'm texting this to you I
know I'm looking it up right now there's
so many comments though
like she literally wait I don't even see
it
did you text it to me yeah
Jackie yes I'm a toaster no [__] way
all right so Jen Gardner you're a
toaster prove it come on the show
prove it Chad
yeah but she literally like said it can
it just be enough for someone to say it
it's um I don't believe I'm you know
what I'm so riddled with like and
crippled by self-doubt I won't believe
it till she comes on and looks me in the
eyes and tells me I know no you still
wouldn't believe it 100 I'd be like
you're lying who said who said this out
no it's like that story of like the man
and God and he's like drowning and he's
waiting to be saved oh my God that is so
weird that you just referenced that why
because I always think about that like
just that whole thing and then in this
book that I'm reading it was referenced
oh wow because like you could get all
these signs but you're still waiting for
the big sign and then God's like I
literally sent you all these signs right
right and that's I was looking at my
time hop and a year ago we had this
whole thing with Kylie being a toaster
yeah and it's crazy because I had all
the screenshots on my phone I'm like we
literally said post a picture of your
nails and post a picture of a tree and
she did and she did and then we kept
waiting for more confirmations but it's
like you're so right but she sent you a
boat he sent you a helicopter
she is speaking facts you're so right
Jen is a toaster period period She said
no question mark She's Not Jen is a
toaster no Jen is a toaster period so
back to our original Point she obviously
has joy in her life she's right full
happy life she has wonderful business
she's wonderful family she listens to a
wonderful podcast I think Jen is just
fine I mean I don't know how you could
not be fine when like you are
responsible for Jenna rank like I don't
know how you could create that piece of
art and not be like the happiest most
joy and of course life is hard for
everyone you never know what's going on
behind closed doors but I think at its
core you can't be Jenna ring you don't
have that in you if you're not a deeply
positive person it's true and to like
have accomplished that Artistry is a
very fulfilling feeling must be like
when Michelangelo did the Sistine Chapel
he was like feeling fulfilled and proud
of himself and you know what this talk
is making me feel like I want to do
you know what I'm gonna do tonight I'm
going to a party in a limo you should go
to your events this weekend in a limo
actually make them drive through Times
Square even though that's not where
you're going okay wait you wanna hear
the weirdest thing at the Jonas Brothers
concert last night they had these three
girls come on stage and like read a
passage from their book or whatever and
just like set this stage of like where
they were at at the time in their lives
When lines Vines and trying times was
coming out and one of the girls was
wearing the Jenna rink dress
it's gone viral no I know it's just like
it's kind of weird so cute such a cute
dress it was just like I don't know I
just thought it was weird it's like
wearing it's just like an iconic dress
known for one thing so to wear it as
like on stage as a Jonas brother like
cast member I don't know I just thought
it was weird I like it there's nobody
else think that's weird uh because I
like I like it
are you ready for our next story that
you just sent me and I'm obsessed with
okay if it's the next story that's
brought to you by
the farmer's dog
when you look at bags of dog food you'll
see pictures of bright carrots juicy
steaks but once you open the bag all
you're getting are burnt smelly pellets
dog food needs some fresh thinking feed
your dog the farmer's dog like I do it's
real it's fresh it's healthy food with
whole meat and vegetables it's gently
cooked in human grade kitchens it
preserves their natural nutritional
value excuse me so I started
um the farmer's dog a few months ago
because Theo had been like fluctuating
with his weight and his coat was getting
kind of dull and I just felt like what I
was feeding him was not cutting it
anymore
um and I really am glad that I did
because I've noticed such a big
difference in Theo's weight he's been
like way more consistent with his weight
his coat is really shiny
um it is so easy it comes pre-portions
there they come in ready to serve packs
they're convenient conveniently
delivered on my schedule so dog people
all across the country have ordered
millions of meals from the farmer's dog
it's never been easier to invest in your
dog's health with fresh food knowing
that Theo is eating food that like you
know
is similar to the food that I eat it
smells fresher it looks fresher it stays
in the fridge in the freezer like it's
real food it just feels better than like
pulling out dry pellets from a cabinet
and if you've been thinking about
changing get 50 off your first box of
fresh healthy food at the farmersdog.com
toast plus you'll get free shipping just
go to the farmersdog.com toast to get 50
off that's the farmersdog.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by modern fertility for a lot of us the
start of the New Year feels like the
right time to schedule doctor's
appointments and check in with where
we're at health-wise but what about your
reproductive Health well that's why
modern fertility was created it's an
easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick you'll mail it in with a
prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within six business
days you'll get insight into your
hormone levels like your ovarian reserve
other important factors that can impact
your fertility the results really go
deep into what every hormone means and
you can also download the results to
review it with your doctor
um to think about next steps you want to
take based on what type of information
you get back from Modern fertility and
as we all know traditional hormone
testing at fertility clinics are really
expensive they can cost over 600 but
modern fertility tests the same general
set of hormones that they do at a clinic
and it costs only 179 and if you use our
code modernfertility.com toast you'll
get 20 off your test so your test will
be 159 and you can get reimbursed for
the test through your FSA or your HSA so
if you want kids today or maybe one day
in the future clinically sound
information about your body can help you
make the decision that's right for you
right now go to modernfertility.com
toast because modern fertility is
offering our listeners 20 off the test
so that means your test will cost 159
dollars which is a fraction of what it
would cost at a fertility clinic get 20
off your fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that's
modernfertility.com
t-o-a-s-t thinking about infertility for
sponsoring today's episode check it out
great our next story Mr Beast is
stirring backlash after asking fans to
fix Walmart displays for his feastables
chocolate bars so Jimmy Donaldson the
stunt YouTuber better known as Mr B's
tweeted an unconventional request to
followers on Friday sparking backlash
and inspiring memes so we posted photos
of he has a chocolate bar and snapped a
candy Line called feastables he posted
photos of those
Tings on the Shelf at Walmart and some
of the displays are fakata and he said I
need your help next time you see
feastables in Walmart and soon to be new
retailers if you could clean up the
presentation and make it look better
that'd make me very happy I'm building a
team to do this routinely just need help
in the short term so they the feasible
account also shared that fans who clean
the Walmart displays can enter a contest
to win five thousand dollars
participants have to submit before and
after shelfies of the display to be
considered for the monthly drawing
according to their website so some fans
are participating and being super
respectful and like are helping out
their boy
others appeared more unsettled by the
request several criticized him for
asking fans to work without compensation
someone said quote it's fascinating to
watch the stage of capitalism where
people are honored to do free labor for
rich people that don't care about them
because they feel some kind of
connection and loyalty like a dog
wanting a treat only the treat is an
imagined feeling of connection or
potentially five thousand dollars but
okay go off someone else said God if I
had 14 million every time a rich person
asked poor people to do Free Labor also
some other memes respond one actually
really made me laugh it was like a guy
tied up and I saw that it was a picture
of a guy like Bound in tape and it said
Mr Beast I caught
I caught this man after his shoulder
brushed a feast of both
after his shoulder brush if he stipples
display and one of your chalk
and one of your chocolates fell to the
ground
he is pleading for Mercy but I do not
believe he is
how shall I deal with this sir [__]
funny hold on my headphones okay and
even though oh and then another one is a
meme it says when you don't organize Mr
BEAST's chocolate bars and it's a
screenshot from his video call yeah I
hunted 100 people anyways even though
I'm laughing as he seems because they're
really funny I I thought what he said
was really nice and I have no issue with
it and if the people don't wanna if his
fans want to help him out that's really
sweet like it is really hard to you know
get out like hire enough people this is
a problem like the biggest companies in
the world have yeah and so if you are a
fan of his and like want to help him out
here I think it's a really nice thing as
far as it being like free labor like it
takes two seconds just like make
something nice and you can enter to win
five thousand dollars like this is so
harmless people like love to comfort Mr
B's and I feel like he's actually a
really easy person to defend because
it's not like he's just getting rich off
feastables and laughing in his Mansion
he's donating like almost so much of the
money that he made he literally donates
all the money he makes right he doesn't
he's yes he's like rich but he's not
like you know
flamboyantly wealthy like he literally
gives money back that's the point
everybody he always says like every
dollar that comes in is meant to go back
out and by the way I saw this tweet
organically like when he posted it and I
didn't think anything of it I'm like oh
that's actually pretty smart if you have
that sort of like loyal fan yeah like
you have like these boots on the ground
uh people who just like want to help him
because they like you not because
they're a dog waiting for a treat
smile down on me like and he wasn't
asking people to drive to every Walmart
in their state they're like he's like if
you're at Walmart and you're like or
buying it or you're passing it like just
give it a little refresher honestly
I'm not a Beastie Queen but I now if I
see it like I would fix it up for him
like it's so nice no it's holding a gun
to people's head right and even if this
he was just like an influencer who was
had his product line and all the money
comes to him and he wasn't like this
charity focused influencer like I would
still be inclined to defend this ass
because I don't think it's that crazy
but the fact that like knowing he's not
just like sitting around getting cheap
right labor from people like he's giving
back to everyone in every way like
there's no crime done yeah no I think a
lot of like the funny memes were meant
like in good fun but then people over
here being like this capitalist [__]
free calm down like just so don't do it
no he's not holding a gun to anyone's
head I mean he said he's work it's not
like a long-term solution it's a problem
they're having that they're trying to
fix but in the meantime you know if you
happen to be in Walmart I really don't
think it's a big deal no I really don't
at all I think it's honestly a pretty
um
crafty idea you know how to Galvanize
your fans and I I have no issue with it
though the memes have cracked me up no
they were they were extremely funny yeah
so um everyone just calm down okay yeah
like I feel like people are always
coming for Mr Beast like and he's really
never done anything wrong it's like on
the one hand I always am going to
be inclined to defend and influence or
under attack yeah on the other hand I'm
always going to be inclined to defend Mr
B's because he's like a charitable
influencer like he's only ever trying to
do good no and there was like a big
takedown of him by that you know brain
dead writer who we know
um
and I think like his crime was like a
couple of years ago he said the r word
and like let's just be honest with one
another like who hasn't you know no when
we were in high school I'm just gonna
say it now like oh my God every other
word out of my mouth was the r word I
like it was ever everyone I knew did so
I'm just saying like that's the worst
crime we'll be okay no and it's like you
just like to hold someone and judge them
based on like the smallest worst thing
that they've done in their entire life
of good work like right are you blind
right no you're not blind because Mr B
secured your blindness
though he is ableist for doing so turdy
right right he is ableist for doing so
um yeah the thing is like I low-key know
nothing about Mr B so I just like always
find myself defending him because when I
see his content
um and it's never like I'm actively
seeking it out or always he's so viral
it just comes across my desk he's
literally like thinking of new ways to
give ten thousand dollars to like
college students but to help them with
their with their loans to give them new
computers literally he went to London
like I think a few weeks ago with like a
suitcase full of new iPhones and we're
just giving them out to people on the
street people were like crying like what
are we doing why are we actively trying
to take this person down I don't know
and you know what the more successful
feastables is the more resources what's
his name has to buy more iPhones wads of
cash share more blindness right like you
know what I'm here for you know what I'm
driving in my life I don't see Mr
BEAST's stuff anywhere because I'm not
like on YouTube and my category
definitely wouldn't be stunt YouTube
like every time I see it it's not stunt
YouTube they called him a stunt YouTuber
because he has like these stunts like
going around London giving out iPhones
is a stun it's a good one but like yes
anyways every the only time I see his
work is because he's like getting some
sort of backlash and every time I'm
confronted with like what he's up to I'm
like
this is a great guy yeah
so I've never seen a piece of content of
his that made me dislike him yeah that I
was actually like do better beast right
do better beast title
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
um itching it's just no laughing matter
and I want to get through the details
because the headline like makes it seem
one way but there's just a lot to the
story anyways
a former Family Feud contestant is now
accused of killing his wife and when he
was on Family Feud He joked on the show
saying that the biggest mistake was
saying I do now listen up a former
Family Feud contestant who's accused of
killing his estranged wife joked on the
show that his biggest mistake was
marrying her that's not what he said but
okay Timothy blifnick and some of his
family members were contestants on The
Game Show and family feud in an episode
that aired in 2020. Steve Harvey asked
like Nick what's your biggest mistake
you made at your wedding and he said
honey I love you but but quote said I do
as the biggest mistake Family Feud like
you have to think what other people
would have said right so he said not my
mistake not my mistake I love my wife
I'm gonna get in trouble for that aren't
I the episode was originally taped in
the fall of 2019 according to Fox News
blifenick was charged on Monday with two
counts of first degree murder and home
invasion in the death of his 41 year old
estranged wife Rebecca blifenick who was
found dead in her Quincy Illinois home
on February 23rd after she didn't pick
her kids up from school the couple was
going through a divorce at the time of
the slaying
okay so wait hold on they've been
separated for two years the attorney
told people
um the attorney said that her client a
sales executive who starred in football
at Quincy University in Illinois
maintains his innocence uh someone from
the community said quote he's never been
arrested for battery domestic battery
anything violent anything ever he was
fully employed there was tremendous
pressure from the community for an
arrest to be made and naturally the
estranged spouse is going to be the
number one suspect regardless of other
circumstances this is the attorney who
said this he was active in the community
he was a youth football coach he was
actively involved in his church here a
lot of people knew him it's very
surprising that this is where the family
is at right now he's your standard
All-American Midwestern dad uh they said
there was evidence of a break-in at the
home and that's an allegation that
police are still looking into based upon
evidence that they've sent to the crime
lab and other evidence that they've
collected along the way she added that
there was a window that was broken but
it's not clear if the window was broken
from the outside or the inside
um
so he's been arrested for the murder of
his wife in this article I'm not seeing
details that make it clear what evidence
supports that it was him aside from the
fact that they were estranged and he
said this on Family Feud which obviously
doesn't age well no it doesn't it
honestly ages completely fine I think
the headline I agree is misleading
um he wasn't speaking from his personal
experience he was trying to win the game
um
so I just think it's crazy that like you
know this
uh case is going on and these people
happen to be on Family Feud that's what
I think is crazy yeah no it's there's a
lot of craziness crazy coincidence is
the fact that that was even the question
on his particular episode
um so he is accused and has been
arrested for her murder but it's ongoing
and
obviously his attorney is going to say
the nicest things about him of course
make him seem um innocent innocent but
there's nothing else in this article
aside from them having like being
estranged that would point to like why
and how he did it right I'm sure there's
evidence because like the police didn't
just go around arresting people right
without evidentiary support and like a
warrant evidentiary support
um but
we shall see so this reminds me of that
Judge Judy episode with her bailiff you
see that clip no
it was like
if there's an episode of Judge Judy and
the the
um the person who was in the court like
was being accused of something
um with his wife and then he said Point
into the bay life and said that guy
doesn't look happily married and
everyone laughed whatever and then like
a few years later bailiff accused of
killing his wife
you're kidding no
Judge Judy's bailiff I feel like she's
had the same one
I don't know I I have to it was like a
video like a that was going recap video
recap video that was going about I don't
know the details let me I could I could
Google Judge Judy bayliff murder
Judge Judy bailiff murder
judge I mean it's like a tick tock video
so but yeah famous TV show bailiff
accused of killing his wife
or maybe it wasn't Judge Judy maybe it
was just another Court show
I love Judge Judy Jewish Queen judicial
Queen Rich Queen I love that for her
yeah
anyways I'll send you the video when I
when we're done here please do
um well that's our show we weirdly went
over an hour even though um there was
nothing to talk about but you know what
I had a good time I did have a good time
and you don't like need to know these
stories but I felt like they were fun to
talk about
right
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the Millennium Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
on Spotify iTunes sister public radio I
already guess box all the places
we are hope you guys have an amazing
weekend stay safe you know follow us on
Instagram yeah and engage with our
content if you know that's what we're
here to do instead this podcast to a
friend if you watching every one of you
got one person to be a toaster then we
are now Jackie don't act like Mr Beast
having other people do your work for you
yeah but send this podcast to another
[__] and make her become a toaster and
then our number is double overnight yeah
our number's double overnight love that
love you guys bye love you bye